majority of women they need to  understand this right mandum we have two  separate categories right we have one  category which is for fun and then  there's the one category that is for  seriousness You Feel Me Now understand  when you see all these in-star hoes  sorry can I say those that that insta  host and all that that who are you know  dressing up in their bikini and all of  that that's us mandum like just enjoying  a woman who is being you know showing  off a body and all of that but that's a  separate category ask mandum when we  want to take someone seriously we're  looking at different things and that's  not usually the whole things that  majority of women are showing off these  days do you understand there's two  different categories that's the fun  category and the relationship okay well